炒股十年我有七八年是个傻蛋
直到我读到一篇公告
彻底改变了我的思维逻辑
大家好
这里是易正宜
今天分享我的炒股顿武机缘
希望能够成为你的机缘
回想过去
炒股真的很头痛
除了要应付各种股票的变化
还要应付各种炒股技巧
教学的洗脑和别人的规劝
回想起来
这些杂音才是炒股最大的危害
但是我们散户必无可避
每个人总是要经历这一步
物性高的可能很快就摆脱这些杂音
大部分人都是难以摆脱的
当我用均线的时候
别人说均线特别垃圾
劝我应该用筹码
但是当我用筹码的时候
别人说应该用MACD
说什么筹码没有十年八年用不好
劝我用MACD
用MACD可以分分钟的做涨停
当我用MACD的时候
别人说指标都是垃圾
用K线才可以轻松的做涨停
而且整天说轻松能够做涨停的人
为什么在我这里千难万难
到你嘴里就那么轻松呢想不明白等我用了K线啊就有一些文章视频啊说K线什么的主力都可以做图啊应该研究基本面一家公司的业务豪啊
拿它三五年
不可能不涨
巴菲特就是这么干
成为世界首富的
基本面是这么个理
可问题
做短线看什么基本面
全职散户炒股
那点钱啊
全都是积蓄
这三五年啊
没啥事还好说
万一家里或者自己有个事
这些钱是绝对拿不了长线的
全职的人如果做长线早就饿死了
做长线大部分赏铺没有那个命
多拿一天自己的股票跌了
别人都涨了
都会觉得错失了千八百万
拿一个月绝对是我以前持股的极限
当然也有拿几年的股票
那就是被套着的股票
以上状态我一直持续到2018年底
没错炒股10年有7、8年
我都是在原地踏步
我都觉得以前的我是个傻逼
后来无意间我看到一篇证监会的处罚公告
里面披露一次内幕交易的过程和处罚情况我找到对应的股票进行仔细的研究发现操作的这个股票也就涨了20%多我记得是24%左右别人就出货了我突然明白
这也是主力
这主力和我想的不同
然后我又去找了很多
证券类的案件进行阅读研究
发现大量的这类案件
他们的盈利目标
并没有我们想象的高
我突然间醒悟
主力也是分等级的
一类是做案
一类是做谈
一类是做投资
只有做投资的才能做得起波段
做盘和做案这两种阻力都求快
盈利目标也没有我们想象中大
然后我统计了几十个案例
发现他们的拉伸空间会大概率集中在
30%和50%之间
我在股市的开悟
主要就是研究别人的犯罪案例
正是因为这些研究
从此奠定了我自己的三个核心交易逻辑
第一个明确主力的内别
让我告别过去对主力庄家的理解混乱
就好像突然间看懂了敌人的移动路线明白了敌人的作战策略第二就是空间有了自己的空间法则并且用空间思维呢引导我去分析和交易股票
那这一点呢我们后续会分享
大家可以关注我们一阵营
第三啊就是主导行情
市场在一些时候
市场或者个股啊
在一些时候是会被刻意引导的
也就是被一股力量牵引和主导
我要做的就是通过技术手段
发现主导的力量
虽然我自己的教育技术
也叫做主导行情技术
当然了
大量的研究
我还总结了很多的特点和细节
那这里就不聊了
后续有机会了
我们会出视频
单独的去做一个分享
炒股思维的改变
变得越来越清晰
越来越明亮
终于我有了自己的交易套路和逻辑
因为上了一个门槛
现在我看很多自媒体的教学类的内容
我是完全看不下去的
我关上了过去的大门
从此杂音进不来
虽然我自己也去讲技术的运用
但是我就是看不进去别人的东西
我也很想学习
但是我学不进去
好 那么今天就聊到这里
感谢大家关注易正寅
我们下一期再见